hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the
second pogchamps championship we said we
were going to cover at least one game uh
from the tournament uh like we did in
the previous one when uh voy boy faced
the
hutch uh here we have rumai wang also
known as hafu in the streaming community
she plays mostly
uh mostly uh hearthstone some teamfight
tactics in the world of warcraft and
uh yes terkelsen also known as gripex
a long long time ago when i was still
playing league i i used to enjoy his uh
leasing compilations he's quite quite
the legend with this champion so
if you guys are into league do do check
it out it's quite uh
quite the quite the feast for for the
eyes if
um uh if you enjoy such a thing uh but
here they
don't uh play any of those games here
they face in the the greatest game of
the
of all uh and of course that is chess so
let's see what happened here it's uh
quite an interesting game with
uh quite a few interesting pause the
video moments so without further ado uh
let's check it out and we're going to
discuss what happened in the entire
tournament um
after we check out the game so uh half
with the the white pieces opens with e4
we have e5 by graphics uh
and knight to f3 now uh sorry about that
uh with knight the c6 and now bishop the
c4 so half goes for the italian game and
bishop to c5 so the joko piano is on the
board
uh and of course uh even in pogchamps
the evans gambit is not played so c3
continuing in the main line of the joko
piano and now knight to f6
attacking the e4 pawn but d4 showing
that
uh she knows what's happening and the
treats the position
as this position should be treated e
captures on d4
and now e5 advancing the pawn c captures
uh invites black into the greco attack
after knight
bishop c3 and bishop before chicken
knight c3
but that's uh uh for for a different uh
video
uh i i guess so e5 challenging this
knight and here
uh this has been tried many times
especially in in the older days and if
black doesn't know that the d5 is the
only good response here
black is going to be in a lot of trouble
here and here graphics goes for
knight to g4 instead uh just moving the
knight
and the way you want to play this is d5
you challenge white's bishop and after
this
bishop to b5 uh maneuver then you go
knight to e4 and the game continues
captures on d4 bishop to b6
and black will be very happy but here we
have e5
and knight to g4 so with some maybe
ideas
could be some some action possible here
on the f2 pawn if this pawn ever moves
uh but now comes c captures on d4 of
course uh
challenging the bishop now bishop back
to b6 and here
well he could go for h3 just challenge
that knight as the knight really doesn't
have
any good squares here you'd have to go
to h6 then white can mess up black spawn
structure at any point
there's no rush here huffle just castles
you can always play this h3 idea
we have d6 and now there is one game in
the database where
bishop to g5 was played but here half a
goes for h3
and it is as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens of course the
knight really doesn't have any good
squares
so knight to h6 seems to be the only
move and now
still not rushing with bishop to g5 or
bishop captures but rather just
continuing development if black castles
we can always capture them with bishop
captures on h6
so bishop to e6 now here you should
black is really in in a very messy
position d captures an e5
kind of prolongs the game but uh uh
castles also isn't really all that
impressive you can just go bishop g5
and next you can capture a bust open
black's king side
but here after bishop to e6 black really
uh really is in a in a terrible position
because he allows d5 with this
very nice uh well with this very nice uh
double attack so here we have
d5 and now graphics goes for knight
captures on e5
he says okay you capture my bishop i'm
going to capture your bishop which is
also undefended on c4
however we have knight captures on e5 d
captures on e5 and now
d captures an e6 saying that okay now
even if you trade queens i always have
this very nice in between
upon captures on f7 so queen to f6
avoiding the queen trait and now again
not rushing anything but knight the e4
with an attack on the queen we have
queen to f5 and here
it's uh it's uh well it's uh a bleak for
for black at best uh so feel free to
pause the video and find
the winning idea for white here uh while
i give you a couple of seconds and that
by that i mean the quickest winning idea
for white
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations it's actually a
mating four and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to d7 check
king has the moo king to f8 only move
now you advance here
to e7 with check and after the king
moves
now you deliver the final check uh and
after the
uh the queen is captured uh pawn
recaptures with a promotion of the queen
and this is now checkmate
however hafu doesn't go for this uh
instead of after this queen to f5 move
she goes for knight
to g3 attacking uh the black queen here
queen back to f6 and only now bishop
captures on h6
so g captures and now e captures on f7
as the defender of the f7
uh square has been removed so this comes
with check we have king to f8 and now
queen to e2
so even though the game is still still
goes on it would be a miracle for for
black to pull through here
so rook to d8 uh developing the the rook
and now
rook a to d1 challenging blacks
one of black's only active pieces with
bishop to d4
avoiding the trade and now again knight
comes to e4 challenges black's queen
queen to f4
and now g3 pushing the queen further
back queen to f5
and now comes king to h2 improving the
position of the king a little bit
black tries to do the same with king the
e7 now the rook can also be activated
but now bishop to d3 threatening a lot
of nasty discoveries here
so queen captures on f7 uh getting rid
of that a very nice pass pawn and now
bishop to c2 huffo prepares bishop to b3
to get the bishop to this diagonal but
we have queen captures on
a2 now preventing this uh we have queen
to h5
and now queen back to e6 not allowing um
any trickery here we have queen to h4
check
and then now comes a very very tricky
move with
king to d7 but now it's really game over
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding
both the fork and the pin and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's knight to c5 with
check uh with the beautiful fork here
and of course the bishop cannot capture
the knight as
the rook occupies the same file as the
black king
so here king d6 and here the queen gets
eliminated
knight captures on e6 king captures and
the queen to g for
with check we have king to d5 and the
queen to e for
king e6 and now bishop to b3 check so
black king is definitely running out of
squares here
king of six and now queen to f3 with
check we have king to e7
and now again not going for queen to f7
check but rather rook
after e1 uh just getting more pieces
into the game you have to
uh you have to also be mindful of the
clock
so we have rook h to f8 attacking the
queen and now queen to h5 even allowing
the capture on f2
so this is exactly what gripex does we
have rook captures on f2 with check king
h1 and now rook
d to f8 and now it seems like there
could be something happening here like
if you could double rooks here
let's say rook captures and bring the
other rook over here then
you might have some uh drawing chances
or
or maybe even winning chances but uh
hafu doesn't allow that
rook captures on d4 there was also the
very interesting rook captures an e5
line but
uh it just anything wins here so real
captures on d4
uh of course the rook cannot be captured
and now you don't really have anything
rook to f1 white just trades and it's
very happy so
challenging the queen but now even rook
captures an e5
we have king to f6 and now rook captures
on f5 we have rook captures
and now while every move is winning in
this position halfway goes for the for
the most poetic one
queen captures an f5 giving up the queen
as of course you have plenty material
uh to to to win the game as it is so
king captures and now king g2 and now
it's only a matter of time and technique
so h5
and g4 with check we have captures
captures king g5 and
bishop to d1 now defending and now the
rook is ready to gobble up all of the
remaining pawns so
c5 gripex will try to maybe maybe get a
stalemate you never know
rook d7 and now b5 with captures
uh this rook is now of course uh uh
transformed into a pig
uh king to f4 and now rook captures on
h7 we have king to
e4 and rook to d7 cutting the king off
from the defense of the
of the black pawns we have c4 and bishop
to e2 now
king e3 and bishop captures on c4 giving
up more material
as yeah i mean you uh one being up one
rook
is plenty so b captures on c for and now
g5
huffle starts pushing her past pawn we
have king f4 and now
g6 with king to f5 g7 king to f6
and the g8 with queen we have c3 uh
trying to get some sort of a stalemate
and uh if you capture this it's still
not stalemate but
um huffle doesn't wanna wanna mess
around queen f7
king to e5 and now queen e7 check king
to f4 with b
captures on c3 making sure that black is
not stalemated so king f5 and now rook
to d5 with
check king to f4 and the queen to e5
with
check we have king to g4 and now it's
made in one you could do it queen g5 you
could do it queen g3 but
hafu does it with rook to d4 and this is
now checkmate as the king covers these
squares and
uh the black king has nowhere to go
so yeah uh that's uh that's the game uh
before we
uh before we uh finish up uh we will
check out
the the brackets from from chess.com so
here's who who gripex defeated all the
way to the finals as well as who half
who defeated so
uh first graphics defeated david pakman
uh then dog dog and then in the finals
met half whereas halfway defeated forsen
uh then tf blade and then uh in the
finals uh defeated gripex to win
the the pogchamps championship the
second poke chips championship
so quite the game uh showing that uh she
knew what was going on in the opening
with that pawn sacrifice on d4
advancing the pawn to e5 and uh well
it was uh mostly a one-sided match but
uh that's
usually what happens when you fall into
your opponent's opening preparation
so uh in interesting game and uh
probably the blockchains will continue
so we'll see who they who they
uh come up with for for pogchamps number
three but until then we're continuing
with our own stuff and the
congratulations to hafu
uh for winning the second the uh second
edition of the park champs championship
so uh once again that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it i would like to
thank dennis nekovich
lolita ramp rampali carlos montero alain
goyet and jeffrey johnson for your
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
yes
the age of kaiser is coming soon